garrett richards last time out allowed
eight hits and four runs prior to that
richards simplified the delivery and had
two consecutive starts in which he
allowed only one run
and a pop-up
and a play for bobby dalbeck who's at
first base tonight
crossing over to foul ground he's got it
for number one
there's another one cut on a missed
strike three two up two down that's a
live fastball with that's what that is
that ball looks like a cutter doesn't it
had some cut action
that's ridiculous that's like mo rivera
he reached back on that one too
a little pop-up again dalbeck on the
move looks like bobby has room he's got
it little lunge at the end and richard's
off to a quick start the big southpaw
shaw manaya making his eighth start of
the season fourth start here at fenway
park and would love to reverse the trend
here at fenway one and two with an era
just north of 13 and three starts here
at fenway
in the center field
can make the play
off the glove chavis wants second a
daring play but he's in
there don't talk about aggressiveness
that's exactly what you have to do in a
situation like this you had two straight
games where you you know you're not
swinging the bats very well all of a
sudden this third game you have to come
out and set the tone one out
and a live shot face it into center
field
chavis will be in to score easily rbn in
a 33 for jenny martinez
and the red sox grab the one nothing
lead there you go there you go exactly
you see how aggressive he was on that
pitch first but just jump on it don't
give him a chance to think and it's a
piece of salad there's a change up right
there look at this thing hit me and he
does line drive barrel thank you very
much here's xander who's over his last
seven and one for 12. he still leads the
thinking hits with 46.
swinging a drive deep down the
left-field line he hooked it into the
corner and it is oh god there it is
that's a home run
you gotta be aggressive
a two-run blast number eight
for zander bogarts it was close into the
corner
boy he snuck it in there didn't he
i thought that ball is going foul he
gets a sinker just i think it's a sinker
all i know is it's middle middle and he
kept it fair a sinker that didn't
did not sink and this ball i don't know
man it got there in a hurry stay fair
he's not sure
he's like
but no need to take a look at it oh it
must have hit the pole had to right kick
off the pole that's the start you need
right there
behind the dish in all three games he
skies one
toward ramon laureano and that will do
it damage done by the red sox bottom of
the second in here is hunter renfro
oh
this one is ripped into the alley
and did that get to the wall in a hurry
he's going to take a base hit on this
he's got to go back to first thank
goodness he stopped at first
that's how hard he hit that ball bobby
dalbeck trying to get going
swing high fly ball that's center field
that's very deep and it is gone
bobby d crushes one
just to the left of the flagpole the red
sox swinging to shalely tonight they
lead it five to nothing
that's exactly what i was talking about
you said yes aggressive jump on that
first pitch jump on the fastball look
what he's featuring middle middle look
at that that's perfect head down short
compact swing
and a blast dead center field
deep short
andrus has it spit out of the glove and
everybody's going to be safe
which should be another base hit
for jd martinez
and that one's ripped down into the
corner that's going to get all the way
to the wall area
safe to say that sander is out of his
mini slump there it is another change up
right there had hit me on it look at
this change up right there here's devers
first pitch popped up
champion over
and he's got just enough room makes the
catch in front of his own dugout side is
retired vazquez will lead it off mania
is still out
a there on the grass onto the track up
against the wall
vazquez with a wide turn red sox are
hitting it so hard tonight they have to
settle for singles
and there's another one look at that
quickly gets on top of canna first and
second under renfro two for two
pounding ball sliding and a knockdown
olson throwing the first varsity safe
and everybody is vasquez down to third
sean manaya does not get an out in the
third inning and the red sox have six on
the board with the bases loaded and
nobody out guerra zoo one
up the middle
on the first to get him and the run
comes in to score on the double play to
make it seven to nothing gary richards
back to the mound for the top of the
fourth the red sox leading at seven to
nothing
they'll put that one in play our ooze on
the attack will flip and get him and a
lead-off man of the inning
out four to three two and two on loriano
with olson on deck
swung on and missed put him away with
that curveball charlie talk to me this
thing stops then it just sort of stops a
little tight spin 12 to six right
underneath the bats
that's a strike too the 1-0 is a soft
comebacker to richards he calmly gloves
underhand flipped the first in time to
retire this side
it's allowed by richards four strikeouts
a couple of walks facing moorland
deep to left center field verdugo is
going to
play it nicely off the wall fires it
back in towards second off line moreland
has a double
about halfway up the green monster look
like for moreland well boston fans let
me introduce you to mitchy dubsack from
the town
stopped again by christian vasquez on
ball four so they're gonna be all loaded
up here
one ground ball to third
fires it in for one and another play
[Music]
five four three as the red sox go around
the horn and get out of the inning
chavis will be next
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
martinez hits it softly
throws that one away though here comes
the run
yeah risky play there by one of the best
third basemans in the business throws it
away we go to the eighth inning the red
sox lead the a is eight nothing
moreland
left field he knows about the monster
orleans gonna make a huge turn and he's
gonna stay at first single in a double
for mitch moreland
olson hits it hard
javis is there and that's the second out
but a run for the athletics is moreland
who took third and then helps the a's
get a run and it helps olson get an rbi
so another inning for garrett whitlock
as he pitches into his third
into right field
renfro back back back
he made the play
boy he had a series nice
he had himself a series and the red sox
win it on a tremendous play by renfros
also involved in helping cut down a man
at home play tonight 8-1